good yeah you the boat you're back doing
episode 8 already didn't really get a
break there Luke what's been the biggest
difference I mean now that Ryan
Johnson's taken over instead of JJ has
there been a big difference on that no
it's still very lovely and warm and
friendly I'm just like 7 1 et was
exclusively with Star Wars actress Daisy
Ridley the force awakens is coming home
to fans April 5th and Daisy's already
back in race shoes for episode 8 is Ryan
just as secretive as JJ I think Ryan
actually wants to live it creepier with
the with the little tidbits of
information that are going out which is
fun he's gonna tease her I think I don't
know I think but I think the whole thing
like it obviously it worked really well
for seven it's wonderful to just give
people a little bit but I think we
actually did do that for seven just like
a little bit to keep you know the
interest no I agree because I think a
lot of it like when we were watching the
trailers were like oh my gosh were seen
so much and then you go see the movie
and it exactly I know obviously that
sound to the wonderful guys we cut those
trailer and everything and obviously a
lot goes into that but it's nice like
even obviously Carrie and Mark putting
up the pictures with their chairs it's
like it's a little bit freer than it was
yeah